[Music]
president Tsai of Taiwan just wrapped a
meeting with speaker Kevin McCarthy at
the Reagan Library in California
now she's been in the United States for
a week meeting with various officials
but it was today's visit that really
ticked off China
this act seriously violates the one
China principle and the provisions of
the three China U.S joint communiques
and Gravely undermines China's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
and it wasn't just words earlier this
morning ahead of head of the meeting
China parked an aircraft carrier group
off taiwan's southeast coast McCarthy
and his group of congressmen weren't
impressed
if the duly elected leader of one of our
most important Democratic Partners can't
meet with American leaders on American
soil
that we're merely feeding the crocodile
that will eventually eat us we must not
be intimidated one thing I would say to
China too at no time I am the Speaker of
the House
there's no place that China is going to
tell me and where I can go or who I can
speak to whether you be foe or whether
you be friend
Speaker of the House Kevin McCarthy
joins me now one of my favorite places
the Reagan Library Mr Speaker great to
have you on tonight now the Chinese
foreign Ministry released a statement
saying that the U.S colluded in allowing
those seeking Taiwanese Independence to
carry out political activities
on U.S soil so they now want to dictate
what we do on our own soil your response
to that
China can never tell us what to do a
speaker of the house I'm going to meet
with whoever we want to meet with with
whatever country look I am not the
general manager of the Houston Rockets
China is not going to intimidate us and
there's no better place to be than here
at Reagan's Library what what it
symbolizes but more importantly remember
yes we have the three communicades with
China but we also have the six
assurances with Taiwan that Ronald
Reagan produced and what we came was a
very bipartisan meeting we had
Republicans and Democrats here speaking
with one voice and you know what we need
to speed up our weapon sales to Taiwan
have we learned anything what's
happening around the world let them
defend themselves deter the ability of
China to enter Taiwan we need to be able
to Foster greater democracy and freedom
we need to be able to work together
economically from the chip manufacturing
and others I found it a very productive
meeting is the first time a speaker of
the house has ever met with the
Taiwanese president on American soil but
I think it was very important in a
bipartisan to matter almost 20 members
together meeting now I loved it and
speaker McCarthy I think it was
courageous for you to go forward with
this meeting uh today but you you
receive virtually no support I'd say the
opposite of support from the White House
watch this there's no reason for them to
uh to react uh in any sort of an
aggressive manner uh but because of it
she's not meeting with any
Administration officials nothing's
changed about our policies with respect
to Taiwan uh and again no reason for
them to overreact
again
bending over backwards to reassure
China
all you're doing is meeting with a duly
elected president of one of our allies
so were you surprised that the White
House
distanced themselves from you
and tried to suck up to China in that
comment
well look at how the president reacted
to a balloon going over our military
bases from China it doesn't shock me but
the difference is today we stood up to
China just like Congress did when the
balloon came every single member of
Congress Republican Democrat denounced
the CCP for those actions and I think
that's what China needs to hear the
China that Congress will act together
that we can allow this authoritarian
view this bullying trying to dictate to
who we can talk to and who we could
speak to when this is an ally this is a
democracy believes in Freedom I mean I
think this this meaning was more
important today than at any given time
and our relationship with Taiwan and the
Taiwan people I think has been greater
than any time in history and again
sitting in Reagan Library think about
what Reagan was able to accomplish peace
through strength defending Freedom now
Mr Speaker Politico recently noted that
China is ghosting this Administration
writing in part that they beijing's
current aversion to sustained high-level
engagement underscores a particularly
fraught nature of U.S China relations
over the past few months what was a
two-sided desire to stabilize an
increasingly volatile relationship is
becoming much more about Washington
reaching out and the Chinese government
demuring
um is this not embarrassing for us that
that by the administration is
essentially begging
with the CCP in China to engage when
China is making it clear they're trying
to displace the United States as the
world's dominant superpower working with
Russia funding the war in Ukraine uh
through its Ag and oil purchases in
Russia as well
look what president she has done with
the bricks to get off the dollar and go
into the Yuan look what they're doing
around the world they've watched this
foreign policy of this Administration
not listening to our military in
Afghanistan collapsing we've watched our
allies now buddy up to China we've
watched his reaction to Saudi Arabia and
now going after this Administration
going after American Energy had made
OPEC stronger which also made Russia
stronger this is a weak foreign policy
has done nothing but teach America we
cannot repeat this again the follow-on
to that though is why should China
continue to enjoy most favored nation
status in trade this is the United
States why
one they should not I mean we've watched
what the past administration president
Trump had been able to accomplish with
China standing up to China so it wasn't
China begging America to talk China was
begging to talk to America but we need
legislation yeah and that's what we need
legislation to watch what our committee
exactly and let our committees take the
action to move forward and do just that
that's what we're doing you saw
Republicans and Democrats together here
meeting with the president of Taiwan
something a speaker has never done on
U.S soil you've watched what being able
to move it forward with the select
committee something that speaker Pelosi
would deny as the right to do it Mr
Speaker I need to move on to some other
big news regarding Trump's indictment
you wrote uh yesterday that Alvin Bragg
is attempting to interfere in our
Democratic process by invoking federal
law while at the same time arguing that
Congress lacks jurisdiction to
investigate this farce he will be held
accountable by Congress
um my question is are you worried that
the response to the Trump investigations
might turn people off from voting
altogether since some people might come
out of this believing that just
everything is rigged they're trying to
get Trump they're they're trumping up
these ridiculous uh you know
investigations against him so are you
worried that people in 2024 are just
going to say to hell with both parties
I'm staying home
well I worry about that but that this
should inspire people to get moved
forward here is a D.A that's playing in
the Democratic process one thing you'll
find with us is we won't sit back he
admittedly is using federal funds and
trying to claim that Congress does not
have a say in this we do I'm meeting
with uh chairman Comer and chairman Jim
Jordan as we move forward on this if
he's using federal funds we have a right
to have jurisdiction and oversee we've
watched what he's doing to the political
process here and we've got to stop this
so for anyone who's sitting back and
saying I shouldn't participate this
should inspire you to participate more
to stand up for the rule of law one of
the greatest strengths of this nation
and join with us as we move forward hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else